ok
he went home
do
yes I think that's better actually
it will pick a police officer personal
identity
230 km civility
I don't
are you kidding
just playful
ferret
so
if they
well
Wow
ng
special someone
thank you
it
indefinitely
how much we live for
yes
it is
business
it is indeed
chicken
fiction is it
Oh
to actually physically different
you blow
district council about Lizzie which adam
khan serious and i have some
that's it both to go through the first
week you see emotions the evacuation
announcement which I'm 34 should we be
equality that way to do energy please
leave school by the nearest available
exit initiative jenga our assembly fight
will be in the public car park beside
the Pacific sweet please do not delay
your evacuation to collect any bit of
pavilions please do not return to look
into getting commissions through so by
cows yourself please know that this
meeting will be audio recorded
absolutely grateful refer anyone with a
mobile phone either foot sits in silence
or sets it off please
oops
touchin wound apologies for absence I
haven't put cheese on it up with gas
agencies through in substituted by my
counselor mr. butcher and counselor set
to be substituted by kept some
supporters or any other apologies okay
no my mistake me see
this isn't meeting so after 4 minutes of
the meetings held over 1737 of mulch
36-3 do you agree and to my sign-
correct bring the right leg thank you
let's apply to receive declarations of
interest that's occurring after
perfection
and general I know the occupant of the
snakes to the National Board businesses
another community that's a war gentlemen
keep the interest
agent
legend 6 land west of Oak Road north of
full house mostly so I didn't check with
your other investigations in the
declaration pinterest language of oak
grove the north for hours rockford to
consider an application to the native
condition 41 an outlier condition for
residential development of 600 Romans
associated access public open space a
new Primus or multi-level classic view
identical to another application
reference same stroke 002 prevalence in
general this application is on the
northern side of all variety of safety
to the westernmost retail sector
generates the lower line and oak road to
cement here in the church just outside
of the
members of familiar this society was
subjective policy s operations plan
which calculates the site practices
since that time science has been rotted
out my commission talk about a second
what's we're on this other drivers worth
noting bearing in mind is this run of
housing on the southern side we're going
to talk about the condition that issue
which affects this party here
we can see the detail of parameters plan
fees when the outline permission was
granted it was subject to gramma suspect
behind various densities and characters
all details that matters were
subsequently worked up he's dealing in
detail lightest emissions what interests
us tonight is this area here is it part
of a wider area another density to front
part of the character of the strip to
replicate books for my identity on this
side carried out through the higher
density me to the site
condition 41 at the out my mission
require this part of sight to the first
was completed ahead of the remaining of
phases of the wackiness part in a hug
the bill Vantage with a public face on
the site and someone scream it from
immunity as you enter and leave the town
of the president's nearby five words
work back and you'll see from the report
if we can go to the submitted I am
pleased with what we rotate that round
and carry on to keep some of the items
in the top topic
what you'll see this report another
hundred ninety
the the Allies of it kinds of these
phases are areas that have already been
approved and to get members perception
of the whole development we've included
the most up-to-date pad which relates to
the phase which is to come before you in
the future there and covered up lines
what interests us tonight this group of
drawings are variously from the report
that affects just a few plots and the
idea was in the condition of a certain
please we built out the others have come
back to the actual construction is
actually depend upon more of this round
the back of trying each the easements
etc so they find some difficulty be able
to complete these persons the condition
requires and instead they would like to
we can go to the detail painting plan
base I would build in these chunks in
these blocks they would do right
solution of their alternative work is to
build these parts before they build back
inside buildings before they build that
bill these in the frontage that
effectively breaking up that long track
that we had asked but giving us the
front
ticular smaller room officers have
considered the practicalities of that
the development of guilty more
manageable slices and we find that we
can support their inquire the submission
of a management plan on the second
button on the hour please they're giving
us a typical example of what they make
imagine this is a larger parties as they
would undertake these works first before
they go rest of the backs you still get
screw and on the show house area etc
before they go back so it's only members
can see that the ambition of the
condition is still accepted by the but
as worthy at the outline strategy
resents the difficulty in fixing their
comfort inquired come back to us with a
suggestive retires condition so the
recommend information chairman is
approvable support
see that from white honey that works at
only spoke about single issue in one
condition he actually requires and
renewed us whole decision roses and
updated accordingly licenses chart
conditions you will see a full remaining
positions also brought forward for you
that's only the purposes of creation the
decision that is correct in the stands
with conditions
his choice
I believe there are no public speakers
on this item so the difficulties are
local to neighbors of equity a
substitute just to remind everybody
there will be a limited five minutes for
each scene there you'll be tired does
anyone we should sleep on these things
get signal sebacean New Jedi will take
five years of Tommy I'm surprised
disappointed that the measurement plan
are asked to take into account and more
particularly to substitute for the
condition 41 is not been made available
now and it will be asked to approve an
open-ended condition which may well put
hard-pressed officers under further
pressure I think the applicant should
have submitted and those band with this
application for us to consider tonight
be completely aware of
in addition the board members so we'll
members present so I don't have a feel
for how residents will feel about this
particular proposal which is actually
not being made in writing that he's
actually verbal I feel inclined to vote
against it because I expect the
developers to bring forward detailed
proposals when there are some change
thank you under the other singers castle
mr. cosmic ocean in front leg through
chairman just to say a few media I think
the amendment we're looking at is about
phasing in life of realizations occur
and how those options if it is but there
are actually no changes that I can see
to the frontages already else are
planning to actually come along if you
like all ok cool I wanna write you
church n on the planet built for all the
landscape design potential which I'm
unchanged what approved it's just an
adjustment how when
what time baby due to get same thing
sort of thesis is less clear channel
vs lee just the question please no just
ask in the offices opinion is this
application driven by practical
necessity or economic desire
the information I've been given by open
prevention about the night something I'm
trying geocities people a lot of they've
got back into the structure in the sides
to serve the front of people right this
way so in order to fulfill the
conditions to occupy those first a lot
of work that happens you can take all
the way through here to make the
astonishing and what they say is they
have to do that in front of must have
your VPS but they can't be a whole lot
before they
anything else attacked AJ okay that's it
black thank you sure
in a question how did this condition in
relation to this
was it a suggestion
all that
general wasn't
I wouldn't be office to dealing with the
outlines you may report is minus values
officers suggestion give them being a
large site having a rather open frontage
they simply English be a good idea to
get the frontage ops group first as the
site work back it was perhaps in
hindsight little over-ambitious to say
the whole practice of Java said the
whole properties but remember not doing
as planners so what my seeing a good
idea to us on the decision-making side
notice come back to society like working
another way 30 sure I don't think
probably whether this couldn't between
what the two moons are the closest
to apply
technicals yes Mason's clients about its
basic not an office that's quite for
that all I can see are also completely
irrelevant
but I don't think the lack of self in
our planning for success this is valid
business refusal possibly have opposed
busting my ass
take it
kissing suppose
mr. chairman Saunders was that they made
that the applicant accepting back the
applicable poutine the original plan our
offices advised they have a 14
not going to be a little concerned that
this early on we're having changes I
would like some clarification it's a
concern that one of the reasons given is
but surely the drainage should be one of
the first things that to Baton before
any society's covered in the sense to
protect the site the neighboring
properties and to protect the building
was going on and I'm concerned I said it
when double to put the drainage in first
we want to dirty sections of the
expected range to be in person
on the impact that the obvious interface
Tom avesta building inspector or
construction manager but my
understanding is
we follow the laser line that's where
the condition said officer said it good
to have that line it's about a dozen
plots bill first now the construction
point
there's drainage servo available today
it runs for any rule through other parts
of the site and what developers do they
build smaller chunks rather than not and
it's been explained to me fighting what
we've agreed this is the first phase of
the planning application for 292 if you
see the red light construction quantity
is broken up into some of the lights
what they need to do is to building
these are probably not clear from the
plan that they're none as to the
individual small faces and say dozens
fifteens or whatever SI be built in
total from when we build a building 20
doctors will become practically build
all that will do
yup excess of course investor
channel D
it helps the spyros come carrying and
all of the main drainage for the site
that venture gets mitigated take our
room already under construction we're
talking about the smallest scale
practicalities to develop our places
where they made income that
thank you
come back
you going
thank you you can just come back on that
point I can see what the office as a
sign about the phrasing of the
installation of the properties but
cannot insurance that as they're
installed that the drainage will in fact
be connected on each section will be
connected completely took two to the
hips that it's going into rather than
just things installed underground and
ending up know where can we have
confirmation that any drainage system
put in will be connected to the overflow
system as as the film goes off yeah i
mean that's that's taking that that that
should be given into the building
control panels because i think they
should only just said it you have happen
in the previous site and we want
discussion with the applicant to make
sure that that there is that last part
management plan that we get indications
apparel don't in a sort of drainage
systems are connected to shoulder that
we meet the concerns of a
prehistoric-looking what i'm asking for
is that the drainage sister is connected
before the sector station goes back neck
and perhaps from that point of view we
could have think all councillors who
will renew or casters to be consulted on
management plans so that can be they
they can have their concerns can be
alleviated don't think there isn't a
concern over the drags on that side you
need a job so can i move that change its
nature so are so invested exceptionally
remote offices now just to take up a
point if I may at Castle mr. Mason by
earlier known in regards to pressures
upon offices to the voice or oversee
these is not happy hour according to
commissioned can I take it because it be
acceptance offices of these charges that
there would not be a goon pressure
content because it's a visitor musical
about the large on a patient there is
already a long-term relationship I'm
always at Lincoln service to become
developable land anyway send this book
the visible part there's all that
discussions hell of sealant important
add that additional pop that condition
right thank you now there any other
speakers castle wall it's just an
observation that the miike snow suit you
worship okay all right I very well
really nothing else maybe it's with my
Nancy's on the gun is it like I've
entrance right I will endeavor to speak
out then perhaps I the speakers will be
deciding in that case we hope to hear
what the guy was the back there thank
you right with the event football by Cao
services Mason can I asked police for a
moment as advice printed the officers
recommendation all those in favor please
raise their hands you know us thank you
lesson 7 item seven we have the speakers
for this YX Simpson there's 10,000
foreign Africans and second city here is
mr. Harry Daniels is an objector that's
obviously very satisfaction my offices
by his son
Selah strong exception to create 50 may
lose energy and so with the site is feel
fear and it's on the corner of the
junction made ways that on Ash engine
road don't you may be church and that
call if up there faintly CEO between
that family at the top of the site air
so just off the northwest and porn or
decide anything tasty actually just if
you look to you have to fight a peaceful
articles and which are here without
building would be moves just pop the
application
so this is the Ariel Ariel you'd be am
the site and then from here before this
someone innovations of the building
beautiful church road and this is the
Western elevation is passionately road
finishing outline planning permission to
use of jun 2014 which was demolished
Garrity said was an algorithm dr.
singleton or extension to provide a team
opens for dinner patients and the moment
their own concerns with this application
but it's inappropriate development
Greenville and as a disproportionate
size extension in relation to the
existing building and it's detrimental
to the character of the listed building
so here's the system not plan and a
proposed block plan and you can see that
it's in the northwestern corner of the
site so that the part mark type black is
the existing building and that's the
proposal courtyard and the application
which you can see when compared to here
is this part here of the site and the
proposal is for a single storey
extension and it will delete existing
building massage tool and that mainly
comprises the existing car park prepare
bone but it also contains to our
single-story outbuildings they're being
previously used to stable storage and
office accommodation and these would be
demolished to make way for those 50 a
motion dementia unit and the proposed
building this but extend past the
existing card fraud and slightly to
shoot into a field behind a campaign and
their dreams office and says through
lumen per building which have access
onto the inner courtyard and so also
activity be contained within the
courtyard and everything
yes in Cyprus veganism opposite
obviously the presentation are being
finished for your information the
deficit these are the proposed
innovations to the north and south side
and so you can see this I think actually
something that this is the southern
innovation so you have the properties on
church road will be fronting here and
this has been more than a lot of
animation of this pit which would be
hidden from view from ashington won't
visit that the properties on the siding
to des moines and this is the eastern
western elevation of the site
so the main consideration is benefiting
the application and solicited building
and in terms of this building it was
concluded that there will be very little
any impact on the architectural and
historic areas with the listed building
or two aesthetic and this is disgusting
that the talent large occasion or listed
building consent and but in general the
science considered hopeful in terms of
residential immunity it was considered
that the impact is definitely not
acceptable because the proposed the
single story and its alterations in the
bridge heart which further reduces the
visual impact and it's been cytisus the
previous reason for refusal was being
cited further away from the rain and
flooding and parking and access 13 car
parking spaces been posed and SS
Pakistan Sanders with a fire maximum pro
tip on space and however the location
France maiden voyage as a breaking bus
service with food connections to both
washer drop the power stations there's
also daytime own store parking to the
nearby King George's public open open
space and as such we considered that
parking provision would be adequate on
the site in terms of greenbelt and OCT
11 of the council development management
plan and seek to support system
businesses
Greenville and provided such extensions
with not result in a disproportionate
addition floor space over the city
additional building it considered that
the substantial increase of thought
Facebook post with resulted to that
matter to be contrary to this policy and
we're took into account the floor space
of the out buildings that will be moved
and even then the outbuildings puncture
approximately 200 square meters past the
post floor spaced approximately 800
sweating
so order for the development to be
considered acceptable in greenbelt it
will be required to about two very
special circumstances the applicant is
stated within our application that there
is a need for dementia services which is
inclusive and then the careful planning
for the future is now needed to ensure
that the right care is available and
figures of incentives such as the
Southeast region region elastics the
number of people living with dementia is
expected to rise the 22,000 to 40,000 in
their 20 30 and in rochford in 2013 they
were 1297 people live in the dementia
ashington Hall has been supporting
people with dementia for a number of
years and the services being supported
by the Care Quality Commission there's a
waiting list of lv people with dementia
who want to move into a [ __ ] at home and
then also insufficient accommodation in
a botched area in last 95 care a review
of Heroes which will I was taken by
application showed SB just 150 pair
those places for people living with
dementia to clarify the past officers
acknowledged that there is a neat the
defense facilities and I'm not opposed
to a patient's residential facilities in
principle they do not consider that the
input information submitted but about
two very special circumstances so a
story of a common concern relating to
inappropriate development blew out the
information provider does not provide
sufficient justification from why there
should be a dementia facility in this
specific cream out location as such
there has been a recommendation of
refusal and based on the greenbelt
refusal that was carried out for the
last application and the resulting
extension that would be disproportionate
in size to the original building and
disproportionate is getting size of two
outbuildings be replaced the proposal
would therefore that result of the
Constitution inappropriate development
okay so good mr. five senses and you
have the five minutes and I'll give you
a call with one minute to go and [ __ ]
lately I will stop the clock than when
you start shaking if Thank You mr.
chairman oh yes I'm a planning
consultant I represent the act occurred
before this application I think
Felicia's give it your shooting through
dress the committee my client recognizes
that this proposal open would normally
be regarded as inappropriate and this is
reflected in the recommendation that the
officers have made this evening however
the National Planning & policy framework
does say that when you're considering
development that's inappropriate in the
green value should that should not be
approved unless there are very special
circumstances the application was
supported by a 50 page document setting
out a range of red special circumstances
principally around the need for this
sort of accommodation floor and dementia
sufferers the officer report that we she
didn't mention that those reflected at
all they have been brought to your
attention as seemingly but it is
important that you do have the
opportunity to consider that there are
very special circumstances
the way that you put on those will be up
to do but the need for this sort of
accommodation is very well documented
there was a report that came out of two
days ago that said that was that whilst
rate of interest had gone down slightly
they were still expecting to be 200,000
additional cases each year there have
been reports done before of the 2014
report by the house hunters and society
which stress that one in 40 of the
population over 65 have dementia by 2015
there will be eight hundred and fifty
thousand people with dementia and that
for class is to increase to over 1
million by 2025 there was a report in
2012 by more the Essex authorities which
also identified an increase and
identified that with in rockford and
parcel pojdem didn't break down further
that that by 2020 there would be over
6,000 243 sufferers in those two areas
as the officer has pointed out there are
currently only 150 floor care hand
places within Rochford
and one of those 49ers various other one
care home that had a very poor report
from the body k became Commission on
share so that shows that there is an
urgent need for this sort of
accommodation within a much Renteria
this is a special circumstance that you
can take into account and you do have a
duty to take it into a cat what weight
you put on it is obviously up to you i
will select at the council sustainable
community strategy one of the objectives
of that is to support the needs of the
aging population particularly as russia
has a higher ratio of older residents
than the national average also the
lobsters aging populations drastic 2014
17 say Supt and the nation will be one
of the main health issues affecting
health people in this district i would
also ask you to take into account that a
fair amount a fair proportion of this
building will be sited on the existing
area of our standing that currently
provide the car park which their
accounting for two outbuildings there's
also a third on the video there's sort
of a third building of state with a will
be taken down my client runs a care home
that receives good reports from the Care
Quality Commission there are waiting
list of people wanting to move in to
their home it's one integrated in two
and community for people with local
people intending application the events
and this is reflected in fact the very
few objections to this application
therefore makes good set of our
inspection problem help and already the
world run home rather than a drum you
learn from somewhere else and therefore
respect regressive getting take into
account the urgent need for this
accommodation and consider whether this
amounts to very special circumstances
sufficient override any harm come to the
greenbelt you would have also noted from
they often record that all the other
projection previously longer exist
securing the impact of this development
thank you
okay so mr. Harry Daniels as an
objective please
you will also have five minutes and
already warned mr. Jeremiah of them and
read the officer's report and he said
listed the issues that he presented
through the council by letter and in the
opposition of this development so there
this 15 bedroom dementia youth seems to
be asked the same portrait as they 18
dimension which was proposed in 2014
they're still going to encroach on
greenbelt might I will of the look with
me and my neighbor will overlook into
three bedrooms directly from our balcony
stuff the home said they could increase
their staff from 8 to 24 BB 13th car
park spaces us was from last time
the surface will only be half the staff
working there at any time so there will
be a different car parking or staff if
there's an overspill because they can
use the memorial hall and come but
without the inside if there's a car
space in church road people will take it
so they don't have to walk and this is
cause congestion because we have people
living in flats faceless that use our
car part of use our road because they'd
only allocated one spins for one flat
which is generally two people to car
sobbing come to ours also in the
emergency services balances do not go
down the side into the home a park
outside which is causes congestion level
time
the cows being partly the others come
down unblock belong to all together
which was stopped at least we do and now
construction vehicles when we mentioned
recently the patch council we asked the
owners how you are going to access to
the sudden the answer was would use the
change car park they did not consult the
church council at any time and that it's
a letter which you should have stated by
no means they have any sort of
permission to go through the top part of
the church some their courses where do
the access to how did it get to the site
you've got their demolition vehicles and
you can have apparently invisibility
prefabricated units brought in by flat
tax saving odds you respect I don't
think we're cooking infrastructure
and this proposed development the road
is so now x webcast canonical past
simplify the entrance to the whole is an
accident waiting to happen because
people coming out of the from the whole
have to come up halfway out before you
can see anything over in traffic i'm a
decision before about the non one scene
tape of yours so today that's all our
gotta save my passion you thank you very
tell me one minute together maybe sell
their immense wishing to see please
casablanca Thank You chef I was thinking
back and over mistakes are made in the
capsules what things also done
differently actually the thing I most
regret this was abdication some years
ago a peaceful place for a home between
about for younger people dimension and I
supported refusal on blue background
there in BS billion can't commit yet
looking but I collapse a mistake this is
a different circumstances it's not a
charity apply here I she made this
religious confirmation
it makes a difference however if there
is one no green grass there's no purpose
and the extra development you without
even think about the house was one if
this happens I think we have to see what
medical infrastructure and what social
infrastructure we need provide it the
agent spoke about reporter to come out
about dementia rates and interesting
because they are coming down good news
is that dementia rates of people about
men we're in early 70s are down buying
nearly heart and overall dementia
stuffings by that will make per person
you shouldn't like that twenty percent
there will be an increased but there's a
lot more older people but needs to be
busy with some hope in the future on
that but I think in the short term
medium term here I'm going to have more
people the community dementia and we
need this to go to John I'm torn on this
one I see that the next application for
this ability to there is only approval
which is baptism remove model introduced
about the cleaner i loved i have
listened to the residents in the base of
good points about to access its eps
etcetera relevant I'm tilting towards
approval as an excessive certain step
I think I think to make sure charism
attention circumstance an hour or a bit
happier if you've been sometimes
independent support representations from
some fun developers probably might
occasionally I'll deal with dementia in
this sense in a good to see something
worth support from there that's how I'm
talking to also put something is an
acceptance okay Joseph Smith ibly you
indicated here mister man are you fairly
close to accepting that dementia care
home is it is close to us very special
circumstance within the greenbelt it is
in degree valve so I would expect a
normal recommendation of you but I do
concur with many of the arguments the
council back has put forward over the
the one area that does concern me is the
is parking arrangements I think that
what has been suggested as a number
compared to what we would normally be
looking for is a great concern we all
know that parking is a significant issue
over lots of different areas lots of
different places around the district and
generally speaking we will take a stand
on off now the number of employees may
be able to cope with the party but
things like a dementia care and came
home to general do have large numbers of
listing professionals that there's quite
a variety of visitors and the the nature
of the candy all around age of the care
specialist nature of the care means that
it's not always provided wholly by the
employees of the organization Plus as a
suspension by one of the speakers that
there is unfortunately the need for our
sometimes time I do believe that the
suggested number of parking spaces is a
compromise too far on this occasion so
if we are moving for refusal I would
like to hear other members opinions on
whether the lack of car parking spaces
should be added as an additional reason
for refusing here thank you catch the
cuddle Thank You Jenny Germans as a
local residents in the area as well and
I will recall that there are parking
issues around there some from time to
time anyway because should at church
road which is the smooth access road
that goes up to the church itself is a
very narrow road you could probably only
talk to a three cars in it at any time
and of course there are driveway so
people tried on to their own driveway
isn't it it can happen in the world
having said that chairman I do compose
the house of Smith in the fact that yes
it's going to be some car parking spaces
but if you're saying that they can use
the memorial hall car park but across
the memorial hall car park has signs up
on it saying this is for the use of
people using the memorial hall or using
the park it's not certainly for those
people who are using facilities nearby
and of course there are shops nearby
with the small frontage as well so in
the Duke barking there but on Saturday
in certain other days when the football
fields or cricket filtering for use that
car park it's extremely crowded it's
full to bursting chairman people
actually park outside on the main road
to
you actually cook you know because
there's nowhere else to park so parking
is a real issue there already I think
it's will only exacerbate those problems
coming forward as far as the actual
Greenville issue is concerned I do go
with the officers comment on this and if
I can draw of members to the very last
paragraph I think 7.9 on papers itself
the statement that's actually made by
officers that gets young there are P I
could put that any better myself chair
and as far as it goes I think there are
right we can negotiate and take frequent
plans that would actually make sure that
this actually fitted into what we wanted
to as far as if ya of building itself
now I'll do except in Charlie that there
are attorney for proper care homes for
people with dementia and other other
ailments and of course this is growing
problem I think that's already but what
goes through that again so this is it
listen this is leading this facility
it's admirable that the the owners are
actually taking this forward but it has
to be done in my opinion in accordance
to their own planning policies which do
steak accordingly that this is still in
the green belt and it has to be very
special circumstances I think it's up to
members to weigh the parents and I'm not
going to direct members on this as to
whether they consider this a special
circumstance or not but at my my own
thoughts at the moment you know to go
for refusal and the haps have an
additional refusal point on relating and
I'll
AO smith relating to the parking which i
think is inadequate picture you move
amendment yes the couple are so a CEO
counselor smith this secondly that and
so we are now seeking to that amendment
other any further and seekers capsule
emotions thank you cheering I'm glad to
hear men that has been added because I
was coming to that particular conclusion
myself look I completely recognize that
social benefits both care homes for
people suffering from all forms of
dementia I'd like to think that even
though we couldn't make a condition on
this but those particular rooms those
particular spaces works particularly
given up to dementia only as opposed to
two other reasons for requiring visitors
again but we can't do that but it's
something I would wish to have said if I
was recommending approval I can see all
of the emotional very special reasons
for allowing this in so-called
Greenville its designated Greenville but
I haven't I know the side too and
there's not much green built in it isn't
covered by hard stand so you know we
have to be realistic however the issues
of parking I agree with the previous
councils Persis mitten couple is real
Church Road is frequently congested with
the current operation just as a resident
described and for my personal knowledge
visiting a friend
they're the issue of using the memorial
wall where the pivotal or not is it is
quite a step away for people who are
professionals trying to get to the care
home for great need also for in a very
busy schedule it takes appointment time
down considerably equally those
relatives that are visiting hopefully
are of a similar age and it doesn't
necessarily age the demonstrates to
measure I know with early onset but we
do talk more of dementia or appearing
post 65 and that distance from Memorial
Hall is not going to be very very good
for them to come and go I see I see that
as an operational issue but from the
point of view of making the reason for
refusal its residential amenity it's the
it's the detriment of wrestling that
residential immunity but those residents
who are living nearby has caused by the
parking and other access problems so
reluctantly I'm going to sum up plus a I
support the motion which is refusal with
the addition of car parking or if the
offices advisors better residential
community making sure okay
capsular water and then Kelly ugly Thank
You Jared to silent I've disappointed
you would be an understatement actually
I'm very supportive of care for dementia
and and to my mind it is and it would be
an exceptional circumstance but and this
is a big part I very disappointed but
when this plan has come forward more
attention was not made to the parking
issue which i think you know is
something which has been highlighted by
members here I would realistically be
wishing to consider this for approval in
the green belt in those exceptional
circumstances but the fact that not
enough provision has been made for
parking and I would have been delighted
to have seen this going back and revisit
it and looked at again because i think
is a great show that this is coming
through as in the way not fully complete
because i don't think you know the
design and as emphasized part you know
and other members are very very knowing
of that area the problems that occur in
india trunk and and how it's this 50 so
you know reluctantly
agree and I mean is extremely
reluctantly but you know is there
another way you deliver this even as a
refer to come back and look at this
again to revisit with parking because
you know to me that is a big stumbling
block where that hasn't and you know I
even some of you be supporting me or
defer on this in regard that I come back
and we present it again with a better
view than how they kind of manage all
the various issues that put member
supply gotcha Maggie Chen thank you
guess we'll just a question of power to
the officer with regards to partner with
cast on Ward are we restricted to having
a single-story car park or all in me
actually go to a step second story
carton or to take on the account I'm
just putting I think issue is that is
the undie either progressive of that
sort of development within degrees out
where we are really need appropriate
this of the actual structure itself any
additional development and that's enough
stuff with some consideration i wanna
cop off he goes on site to show don't
just flirt that the home of the main
green out in that location so it will
need some kind of obsession with
ourselves
the applicant to actually address that
point of I think there's two issues
actually which creates the membership
important is that whole thing around
eight or merging vehicle access to the
site I think that actually what we can't
do is just create lots of car parking
which means that we then can't get
vehicles if we just align them away with
car parking so it's actually making that
system between the needs of the site to
provide and car parking and the needs
that sartaaj provide emergency exits so
I think if members want don't prefer to
go ahead and have this especially if
there is no other speak this thing that
I would like to put my two paths in and
that is the lady's notes or officers
earlier clients regarding the quite
dramatic by oversized the increase in
floor space which I believe even after
the net Cynthia for demolition of
existing outbuildings was something of
the order of 800 square metres compared
to 200 square meters which i think is
slightly over the top I think in terms
of bourbon agreeing about their problems
are alive they do share the concerns
about car parking I'm not in favor of
deferral but we are speaking to the
Magic Castle black we are speaking to
the additional payment of car parking
too
obviously its recommendation cancel that
you had a question I guess avenge our
loss in position he's very scope you get
in designing different car parking
without having to be inside the whole
screen so i must always talk about
writers you also you have to make a
decision what's before you know what
you'd like to happy for you but from it
which is minus comments those indication
that about me push-ups into a very
simple i think there's a bit assuming
this site we've got a we don't have
looked in terms of average assets
industries ears and it's one of our
suspects we can't have this ability that
then it's just surrounded by far part
and then you've got additional problerms
then bring back in probably reason
perfuse around about the harmful
stability of my car parking so it is
actually a it is an issue that members
want to address in terms of a reason
diffusion layer of you can address that
so recent members want to go back in the
dress with
the applicant it blows be a redesign of
the application to dress that up that
issue and learn address against that we
do better line up with the interpreters
degree in Argentina pop art visual car
parking and also been a great Minister
for parking any mass level with it is
about this
can you do that gasps about okay thank
you right in which case the listener
even further members wishing to see own
puts the refusal recommendation for
refusal with the additional payment
regarding car parking to the boat
without a fight sorry okay there's just
one error in the young in the revolution
and for some reason it was integral
managed to put the ball wrong planet and
the it should stay the velocity 2011 not
beyond 2006 documents I apologize for
that error okay now in which case but
most others wishing to shower before
refusal of the amendment regarding car
parking please indicate our place
not quite sir Thanks thank you a better
motion for two years of this season
focus like that
mother I'll move to item 8 oops i
actually bought your son witness this is
the contact page alongside people item
is Felicity building consent abode
consideration for disability should send
way to infect stoic architects
interesting building and no other to
your participation for taking
so against my location which we would
look at and and the proposed block and
this one and the main sort of value of
being a historic building it seems to be
for me the southern and western
elevations and so from here I here so
this part of it up this this is
acceptable and he brought how expensive
this part of the building so I peers or
been are harming arming the southern or
the West in elevation and we've got the
proposed their motives here she might
come back to and the amazing sit
emotions and so the most important use
off on the south and west and the son of
you is the front innovations in those
elegant and support structure that
you've been the wasters of the dock
cable to the back wall which gives the
building a strong character and the
payloads application will connect to the
existing 1986 ocean therefore leaving
the historic past the building untouched
so
for myself so this here was the 1980s
extension
to the current 20th century sanctions to
halt spent much of the historic
settlement being voted and the way in
which the experience of being
substantially altered it's also me to
their substantial physical and visual
separation between historic core
building and post section of the site to
be developed the proposed designs the
courtyards good insofar as its
single-story low-impact and do the fact
that the alteration of your tights and
building and folks up for our audio d is
less visually intrusive sections as such
there will be various toward any impact
on the architectural historic character
at the list of building also accepting
have touched the recommendation of
approval and this application thank you
there are no public speakers or miss
Mercer members into a teen counselor
couple Joe just a technical question
really for my own ignorance if you like
but if this were approved it would have
no impact on England on a matter of
refusal to the previous application this
is just a sexual question thank you
Kirsten oh thank you I'm slightly
puzzled because in 2004 it appears that
one of the reasons for refusal was in
fact inappropriate development in
Greenville this not also in a moment to
moment of the Greenville this operation
is just Felicity building consent alone
so the previous occupation considered
the material planning considerations of
the innovative development that was
considered to pass for planning
application Alyssa those're percent is
purely to do with the sexy of any impact
on honesty building so this this is
approved will overwrite the previous
release in Nordic countries said that
and that particular one didn't just
didn't apply to you listed building it
was considered into the previous and
application to that that is a bit of the
impact of mr. buildings etc okay thank
you
just a clarification I understand that
we're looking at listed building consent
but in the report we have that the
church is also listed building I said
that from the innovations that we've
been discussing you can't see but any
other side of the field the application
is going uphill effectively what the
will that impact then moving to the
other direction what impact would that
have on the visibility of the church
which is in if you're looking for the
other side I think is easy I don't know
inter disabilities and what this
application is seeking because it's only
simple I didn't public apologies nations
and different this is a fact it just
deals with the impact of this
development on that mystic build on the
wahala org actually origin for me there
is different there's different
iterations for actually setting of a
Java during this abilities so this case
is just looking actually at what impact
it would have on the listed government
is attached to and it's my attachment
that
immediately so setting a bit of a i'm
very affectionate emotions
I think your concern about the overall
see no other indications of that
efficiency in which case put the
officers recommendation probably air
those in favor of approval please
indicate that that is unanimous thank
you
later than I make in a year 49 wrote
equal justice but we have any speakers
make a chairman this application further
two members by councillors in traits to
site here from the northern side of the
main road the junction reduction router
here and the fourth row to the further
onto this property and thoreau have a
happy norms with their precise this
putter side of it concerns us
regrettably the aerial photograph is is
out of date whilst this area is intact
men's would be aware that this tract
through here is part of the daily Wilson
homes now which is more or less than
paper policy ser for in your allocation
document which is now almost nearly
built out if we could jump to image for
please the applicants have provided us
with a drone image to give members of
perception up to date outside rests in
here and this is the route of building
that is coming in use for residential
purposes mostly and that
into the presentation and the
application details but while we're on
this image is important for members
senior photograph as it was to realize
that our sighting here like this and it
contained if you will by a larger scheme
as well as the development pattern
nearby I think that our influence
counselor mrs. Green's concerns while
she felt is important to bring it before
members if you can go to the site layout
members will seem that this is an
application to divorce your number
amount of F dot usually from reading the
office with the night screaming in bed
with us the number of outbuildings about
here the proposal is for a new bungalow
in this position and a garage serve that
bungalow together with a garage to the
existing toiling down gear the existing
access that gets you into battle site
currently would be retained for the use
of the main dwelling in a new access if
we can show that to members by slipping
down the drawing in the way please it
would be formed down the other side of
the block the new crossing onto my Road
at this point you can drop the climb
down a bit further please go back to the
back of it thanks that's it the building
on the boundary of the back that I've
tried to show on the aerial image it's
hard on that boundaries of linear
building producing residential uses a
format outbuilding because this at one
stage I think was a form of
horticultural nursery and tractable and
went back into what is now the
redeveloped site and where they form a
new boundary across the site the
outbuilding
you survive very hard on that country if
we can see the allocation playing please
the issue for members tonight is that
the application mercy from the officer
recommendation is in the green velvet
purple you see on the plan is a location
our site is is here so surrounding
development pattern mostly relatively
times your member it was a former
resettlement area where we allow useful
now extensions larger than usual
twenty-five percent 35 spermatids it
used to be that the Greenbelt boundaries
retained all around this Terrace these
houses are all in the green belt this
pot the oil in Greenville as he's our
site here and is an open area of land
undeveloped which is being a case for
number of years the current application
follows actually a previous application
for three days which was refused on this
side and in dismissing the appeal
inspector up held accountable position
that whilst is hot buildings on it all
seems to be photographs the council in
has provided shortly of the glass houses
and the number of structures that have
left and being formerly agricultural
notice placed in the youth it doesn't
qualify for people previous ago think so
the inspector upheld the council's
position that it's a straight window
issue and that the scheme then he bought
in which was the three ways I would have
used the term that I've got down here
somewhere about the increased
urbanization of this area here which is
pretty relatively tightly packed
together with the new development at the
back of subject of release we helped
that actually to develop in this pocket
here would add to that sort of
urbanization locally
and he also said that the background
nature of this development is out of
character locally there doesn't seem to
be any background that you could see
that factored into local circumstances
taken together with that also is the
number of glass houses on the site be
surrounded by trees and growth and in
this location is a number of
horticultural nurseries and Cutler
garden centers whereby those glass
structures large as they are and
unnecessarily out of place members will
see from the report developed during
positive the m21 sets em criteria when
you can consider favorably the
replacement of the existing dwelling
that is on the basis of an increase in
floor space no greater than twenty-five
percent of the building now the building
as there is a sort of a slope roomed out
building and you'll see from the report
for the increase in crawl space is some
fifty-seven percent of the size of that
which obviously is way access at the
twenty-five percent of the policies
would allow so officers consider that
the replacement bungalows oversized and
therefore inappropriate in greenbelt and
that the motorized character of the
existing building needs better
reflecting in the chosen design this
building has a higher designer that
compares with some of the surrounding
bungalows and properties that are there
but from a Greenbelt perspective it has
to compare to the low-rise discreet
outbuilding
seeks to replace now if we can see that
the photographs provided please these
are just walk members through the
circumstances on the site which is go
from quickly one by one I believe that
is the boundary to the open space you
saw beyond if you can drop us at 0 which
i think is more of the same to the next
one booth you'll see that the amount of
sort of ivy and trees and Bradley's
building these horticultural buildings
have been vacant to some time in no new
news source e nature of some are taking
over to go to the next please that's the
new fence boundary i believe with the
day wasn't hosted other now the plaque I
think unfortunately there's like a solid
IRA to adjust the position of the
Beverly day you'll see how close that is
to those against the next ones please
then the new site beyond the cities of
these areas here are where formerly
wife's house is once stood
foundations are still there but in main
structure in some cases if you remove
because in the next please there's one
of the sheds that's on site that would
be removed go to the next place another
shot of that in this one please that's
the condition of the glasses as you see
from the report and they would be
suitable for reuse is something that a
substantial work if we could go to the
next place going another shop this is
the Christian garage that be demolished
and replaced if we go to an ex place
more shots of leaders in buildings and
again both
that is the middle age of the existing
residential burglary remember I said
about close proximity defense line with
closer proximity of the development
bankers in the devotional back you can
go to the next place this is the
position the existing out building as
well as a point a fun place it's another
shot from inside the building the
presidential conversions view replace X
one place and the next month please and
again I think members are getting a
perception for how close the residential
building is to the new development the
back which i think the applicant was
expressing kind of an idea of acceptable
infinity will see from the report that
even though that's a natural position to
type from a Greenwell perspective
obvious is outlined in the report but in
this case it doesn't carry much weight
as as perhaps a lame they might might
think go to a glass of the place
and again
once you look at the photographs you'll
see on the addendum there has been a
further letter received we believe it's
on behalf of an anointed resident of
we're not necessarily care who that is
there wasn't an address outside the
district I believe it's been prompted by
it or somebody who lives near the site
Musgrove a relative to to write in on
behalf that photograph is the existing
access down there is the main road and
up this is just an axis that you can
engage the existing dwelling behind here
we actively being with the accessing
through so the recommendation chairman
is refused now you'll see in the reason
that if you first policy are five is
from your previous local plan subject
change during the first policy p.m.
takes a month will be perfect timing of
the recommendation is beautiful
dosto Mason mr. Dalton thank you i'm
speaking as a award man man who knows
this area very very well i also know the
progress of our core strategy very very
well and the the applicant made a
request to the inspector at the time of
the PE on the allocation of sites to
have this this area included within the
ser for but that was that was defined
and of course our officers have told us
how the inspector looked at the issue of
the appeal or the previous application
an LDC has been one on this site and the
building that's proposed is obviously
considerably larger than that and also
seeks to rationalize other buildings
which as the officers have pointed out
not capable of being included in
agricultural repurpose or redevelopment
I've not heard any very special
circumstances in the reasons for this
being called in I did ask our officers
to give me a proceed or counselor twins
reasons and there was not one very
special reason quoted to agree to this
in contravention of them PDF and our
only development policy would create
some very unwelcome president throughout
our district I see no reason why we
should approve this application against
the offices recommendation and therefore
I move refusal to know
second I don't open up cancel mrs. know
she used to speak on it and not not at
this point in time thank you
just a couple general I think we ignitus
from the previous applications that has
to be very special circumstances when
building the greenbelt I hope this meets
the criteria so I'll happen to support
the notion of you
I see now the indications that we've
members wishing to see the witch that's
put the motion for refusal as printed I
believe that either audition and then
listen to that those in favor of
refusing please show that if you notice
thank you yes i think is the close of
the meeting which is 847
Thank You Jenna I think that you also
miss